we call this monic like a guy trampoline
[Music]
do you want to see something good
example of using smaller tonight we'll
stay here on one chord to the next
where
[Music]
so in practicing this obviously one way
is to practice slowly and then you can
start figuring out with a base mouth
bars kind of practicing it that way and
then I would pay attention to the thumbs
at the top again I practice accenting
just being aware of it then I would pay
attention to the index finger and the
thumb so it would be I at first glance
these two no D flat D flat G flat D flat
D flat G flat but today when I was
practicing I found that it was much more
helpful to focus on this wrist right
here
it's the third interval with exception
to this interval which is the only force
in this sort of patterns and then this
that sure that these are all third uncle
here which is it's different the pattern
breaks anyway these four five beats or
whatever six beats
those I find the most difficult and
being aware of that interval and
practicing it legato and also practicing
it in different articulations I find
helps helps ground these notes
[Music]